okay uh Senator Mitch McConnell talking
about the Border deal he's obviously
very frustrated he initiated uh the
beginning of these negotiations that
were led by Langford and Cinema and
Murphy Republican congresswoman from
South Carolina Nancy mace does not
support it and she says anything short
of shutting down the Border will not
work she sits on the oversight and armed
services committee Congressman May good
to have you with us today um thank you I
I'd like to start by playing a sound
bite from uh the your colleague on the
Senate side Lang
about his reaction to where this stands
watch
this are we as Republicans going to have
press conferences and complain the
borders bad and then intentionally leave
it open after the worst month in
American history in December now we've
got to actually determine are we going
to just complain about things or we
going to actually address and to change
as many things as we can so what the
American people were told congresswoman
was that uh the funding for Ukraine and
Israel and Taiwan wouldn't happen unless
unless we did something at the border
first so then these negotiators get
together and they work on a program to
at least start a to chip away at some of
the problems that exist on the border
they come up with something and now
Republicans uh many of them including
yourself are shutting it down so what do
you say to the American people about
that well I find it very ironic Senator
langford's comments there because this
bill keeps the Border wide open there
are so many loopholes in this bill it'll
make your head spin and any Republican
that supports it supports open borders
because it's going to allow secretary
mayorcas to have full discretion on who
comes in above that 5,000 limit it
lowers the standard for those that are
seeking Asylum and look the American
people are tired of being an ATM machine
for the illegal aliens that are coming
across our border every single day and
the more that I read language in this
bill the more frustrated I get with it
because it's not what we being sold I
think we're all trying to to figure out
this bill have you read all 3 70 pages
of this bill we are we are working
through it we have about 50 pages more
to go but from what we can tell and I'm
going to put forth a statement once we
finish reading the bill the measures
that we feel are extremely undesirable
that keep our border open that water
down the Asylum system um it's not good
for the country they exactly the
opposite that's why I'm I'm asking you
know and obviously uh Senator Langford
and his colleagues you know worked hard
to negotiate something you know it's
hard to do some actual negotiation and
they were they say no new Asylum claims
would be allowed anybody Crossing would
be
removed over this hold on and he said
you know this it ends the whole idea of
I made it to us soil and now you have to
process me it increases detention beds
doubles the dep portion flights and adds
$650 million to expand the border wall
which is the same language and funding
that's in hr2 so you know isn't isn't
getting something better than getting
nothing because this problem isn't going
away way no but when you have a loophole
on the other side of it on the very next
page in the bill that that puts us that
puts a squash on any of that that you're
talking about there um and allows the
secretary Mar orcus allows bureaucrats
to make these decisions rather than
courts that Waters down uh the reasoning
behind those seeking Asylum lowers the
standard for those seeking Asylum um
that's what we're talking about here
that's the language that we're reading
in the bill and for part of what I can
tell is that we're not being told the
truth here about the bill and I'm going
to put out a statement that goes through
it Page by Page just like I did that bad
debt ceiling Bill last year that will
outline to the American people what the
truth is because they deserve nothing
but the truth all right well we're we're
uh covering obviously both sides of this
Republican battle over uh what to do if
anything to to close the border so we'll
continue to share with uh our viewers
both sides of this equation uh as as you
all see it so thank you very much for
being here Congress thank you hey
everyone I'm Emily compano catch me and
my co-hosts Harris vulner and KY
mechineni on outnumbered every weekday
at 12:00 p.m. Eastern or sets your DVR
also don't forget to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights